- [Narrator] When you go to the beach
and you look at the ocean, it
oftentimes might look fine.
But as we'll see in this video,
we, human beings have been
stressing aquatic environments.
And if we're not careful, we
might completely ruin them.
For example, this is what a
healthy coral reef looks like.
And coral are fascinating organisms.
You can view them as little
animals that are fixed in place
because they're releasing
this calcium carbonate
the same things that eggshells are made of
that they're fixed too
and then that builds the coral reef.
But they can exist, they
have their homeostasis
in a particular temperature range
and a given amount of various chemicals
that are in the water.
Now we know that human beings
were causing the climate to warm,
and that's all also causing
ocean temperatures to warm
and as ocean temperatures warm,
many of our coral reefs are
not able to be as sustainable.
For example, this is a
less healthy coral reef.
Some of the coral is still
alive and seemingly doing okay,
but in other places, you see
what is known as bleaching,
where the reef is now white
and that's because in those situations,
the coral is essentially dying off.
Now you might say, well,
this is unfortunate
because coral reefs are very beautiful
and now it is less beautiful.
But what are the other impacts?
Well, all sorts of organisms and animals
live in coral reefs,
get their food from it,
get their shelter from it
and if the coral reef start to die off,
then the animals are going to die off.
On top of that, these coral reefs
that the coral are essentially
building as they live,
they prevent erosion on the coastlines.
So one change that affects one organism
or one part of an ecosystem
can have a lot of follow on effects
on other parts of the ecosystem.
Another perhaps more obvious way
that we've been not being
nice to aquatic environments
is things like oil spills.
And you've probably seen this on the news
when you have major oil spills,
they tend to be pretty disturbing images,
but this right here is a
bird that is covered in oil.
And you can imagine when
a bird is covered in oil,
it's not going to be able to fly,
it's not going to be able to swim,
it's not going to be able to have food
and in a lot of cases,
it is likely to die.
And just as we described
at the coral reef,
this doesn't just affect the bird,
it affects the entire ecosystem,
including human beings.
And this is just the effect on a bird,
it has affects on the fish,
it has effects on the just natural balance
that occurs in that aquatic environment.
Now, another idea that
is less talked about
is this notion of oceanic dead zones.
And this right over here is
a picture of the gulf coast
right off the coast of Louisiana,
I was actually born right around there.
And what it shows is every
year, this hypoxic zone,
which is a zone of low oxygen
levels in the water form
off the coast, and this
shows how bad it is.
The red areas are the
really bad, very low oxygen.
Sometimes you might forget,
and you might say, okay,
for all of us who live in
the land or live on the land
or in the air, we breathe oxygen,
but organisms in the
water need oxygen as well.
Oxygen that has been
dissolved in the water.
And what's interesting is why this forms,
it's actually a little
bit counter-intuitive.
It turns out that chemicals
from human runoff,
especially fertilizer.
So you might not realize it,
but this is the Delta of
the Mississippi river.
And that has run off farm runoff
from as far north as Minnesota
and Chicago and sewage
and that farm runoff and that
fertilizer and that sewage,
as it comes into the Gulf,
it actually promotes algae formation.
And you might say, well, that's good.
Some more life is growing,
but so much algae gets formed
and when that algae finally
dies and it gets decomposed,
the decomposers actually use the oxygen.
Remember, when you are actually
trying to metabolize things,
you're using oxygen in order
to extract that energy.
And so the oxygen in the ocean
in that area gets depleted,
and then you have a situation
where almost nothing can live
in these zones right over here.
And this is just a sample of the things
that we are doing to
our aquatic environment.
And there's other things,
there's elemental sources of mercury
that we throw into aquatic environments,
and it makes the water highly toxic.
There's obviously other
forms of trash, pollution,
that we've put into the water
but this is just to give you a sense
and to start giving you an appreciation
about how imbalanced everything is
and how in one part of
the country say in Chicago
waste that's going into
the Mississippi River
can affect aquatic environments,
thousands of miles away.